yeah welcome again to 8701
um so this is the fifth section of our
introduction
um i'd like to talk about the early
history and the people involved
in nuclear and particle physics i cover
the period from
1820 to the beginning of the second
world war
other elements of the later history of
the development of the standard model
are parity violation cp violation
those aspects will be covered when we
talk about the actual physics involved
but
i'd like to give you some more
background especially since we start the
discussion with particle physics
it's good to understand what was the
starting ground
which shoulders did people stand on at
the time
um important to realize here at this
point i'm not a historian
i like to read about history i just
finished an interesting book on einstein
i'd like to you know have a good
understanding how the people of the time
the time itself and the physics
discovery
interacted it helps me
in understanding the process of
being scientific when you look at
history you find a lot of places where
progress was made by curiosity
and by doing
things which are not the common way to
proceed
and so um one learns this by by looking
at history and i
might give you a number of examples here
as well
so diving in um one of the questions um
at the time you know going back again
almost 200 years is
how old was the earth how old is the
earth um
and about 200 years ago people started
to
argue whether or not you know the ten
thousand of years which we are
long thought to be the age of the earth
are actually correct
um and uh you know specifically
geologists
and biologists argued that this cannot
be true
they observed how slowly
geological and biological processes such
as
erosion and evolution occur
um and and and if you just
you know try to you know by observation
um put all of those uh you know ducks in
a row if you want
um you find that the earth's earth must
be much much older than those ten
thousand years
on the contrary um some
physicists argued that the earth cannot
be as old as several hundreds of
millions of years
because it would be by now a very cold
and dark place
one of the uh opposer
of evolution was lord kelvin of william
thompson
and he argued with classical
thermodynamics
and calculations that the earth
cannot be as old as those 300 million
years as david
writes in initial printing of the origin
of species
um hermann helmholtz a few years later
tried to use energy conversation
principles to calculate
that how much how much heat from the sun
would radiate if the energy comes from
slow
contraction and he kind of um
by converting gravitational potential
energy to heat
calculate that h cannot be more than 18
billion years
so putting those together you find on
the one side the physicist
um theology might be yet a different
dimension to this discussion and then
geologists and biologists and a
complicated question i mean really there
was something to be learned something
was not quite understood
so we'll come back to this question
um
next slide um but then
you know progress was made in the
understanding of physics
and here to be named are um
ori pigeral for example for the
discovery of radium
over the agent from uranium and ernest
rutherford for the discovery
by studying this radiation that there
must be two
at least two different sources of
radiation and he calls them simply by
following the greek alphabet alpha and
beta rays
in the same year jj thompson discovered
a particle
the electron charged particle of the
electron
um the kerrell's story is quite
interesting as he
you know was trying to understand the
material
rontgen um studied um and
you know he was interested in figuring
out what
fluorescence material can do and again
this is one of the
examples where he by accident discovered
that
it is actually not the fact that you
know you have a material
you expose this to sunlight you wait a
little while and it still radiates
the light so this is delay the
fluorescence of the material
is not quite the full story to those
fluorescent to some fluorescent
materials
so you discovered this by accident by
putting a mineral in a drawer
together with a photo photo plate and
found that uh there was only a very
um short you know
limited evidence from that photo plate
to be radiated by the sun
but it was basically foggy uh from being
in the same drawer as a mineral
this was a rather accidental discovery
marie and pierre curry proposed the new
term
radioactivity for materials which in
general emit light and they discovered
additional materials
to the uranium which was
discovered by the kerala so they
discovered thorium for examples and
later also the elements of polonium and
radium and they discovered that
those elements radiate a lot of radio
radioactivity so maricori was able to
measure the energy being radiated and
found that a gram
of radium can emit up to 140 calories
so per hour and and so you find that a
gram
a gram of radium is able to power
basically the energy you need in order
to survive
provides energy
so moving a little forward so then then
or uranium specifically what other
radioactive materials were studied and
paul villar discovered that there must
be a third component of radiation which
behaves different from the other two
and he calls this uh gamma rays again
simply following the greek alphabet
uh and moving along to the third letter
um what the fourth then uh connects
these findings first to the question of
the age of the earth
and he simply uh suggests that it's
those radioactive elements which
are in ores and the core of the earth
which provide an additional source of
feed sufficient
because of the thermal kinetic
conductivity of the earth
to keep the earth geologically active
and he comes to the conclusion that the
earth might be as well a few billion
years old
as we know now it is
so putting this in context at the very
same time
in burn switzerland a
a clerk named albert einstein has a
fantastic year
he in one year comes up with a sequence
of theoretical discoveries
one is special relativity and he uses
the findings of special relativity
to derive that there's an equivalence
between energy and mass
and this equivalence as we will see
later when we discuss nuclear physics
specifically
is very important to understand nuclear
decays
nuclear fission and nuclear fusion
and figuring out why you know if you
have a compound state there are some
that seem to be lighter than the sum of
the individual components making up
this particle rutherford
was a pioneer with collider experiments
in the sense that he used alpha
particles
a lot to bombard alpha about all kinds
of materials
so what he found first is that um either
particles when
when stopped turn into helium so the
alpha particle itself grabs on to the
electrons by
from the material it collides in
huh that was a technical problem i just
continue
um and and it turns into to helium
his students master and geiger then
performs a very famous gold foil
experiment so you all
probably have heard about this take an
alpha particle source
and you shine it on a foil of um
of of of gold and then you look at the
angular distribution of the particles
which
go through or which are being
backscattered from this foil
and they find and rutherford then takes
those measurements
and turns them into a solar system-like
model of atoms which are essentially
made out of empty space and a very small
and dense nuclei
so now rutherford then continues with
this experiment
and is able to produce um
uh by bombarding nitrogen with alpha
particles protons and oxygen
and this is in fact the first human
engineered nuclear reaction
so now we're in the year 1919 just after
the
first world war ended on the theoretical
side this is the time where quantum
mechanics is developed
um and dirac then combines relativity
with quantum mechanics too
you know in in which then leads to the
so-called drug equation which we
going to look in very shortly in this
lecture in class as well
this equation is quite interesting
because it predicts existing of negative
energy states
and so then so that's you know just
comes out of the equations and then
you ask yourself what's what's happening
here you can have an interpretation that
for an electrons those are electrons
which travel backwards in time
or you interpret them as energies as
electrons with negative energies and so
this is then
uh leads to the prediction of antimatter
pauli and fermi um you know they're
puzzled by
a problem of energy conversation in uh
better decays
and so this um is something which you
know is
is rather weird and it's a big challenge
to the physics of the time
and they've solved this challenge by
proposing a new particle which is rather
light
and doesn't interact with the detectors
they had available at the time so it
just
escapes undetected they call this
particle the neutrino
a year later neutrons are directly
detected
in experiments by chadwick with
beryllium alpha particles again
and then the predicted anti-electrons
the positrons were discovered by
anderson
in tracks of photocardiographic plates
which look like electrons but they curve
in the wrong direction
so either they have the opposite charge
or they travel backwards in time
they didn't have quite the time
resolution to mix this up
all right
also on the theoretical side it needed
to be understood how electro
how neutrons and protons are actually
bind together
in nuclei and so yukarva proposes
hideki you cover proposes the system of
a strong force which is
really really strong and binds those
nuclei together to
to a degree that you cannot easily break
them apart
and then beta calculates how nuclear
fusion
rather than the fission process can be
used in order to power the sun
so for this he proposes a steep
three-step process
on the so-called proton potent change
which i will not discuss here but we
should certainly discuss later in this
class
and then there's more developments in
the area of
nuclear
physics and this this progress is made
by again using all kinds of materials in
bombardment
each other so for example by pro
by you know colliding neutrons
with uranium one discovers a process of
nuclear fission
this was done by lisa meitner and otto
haan
in the late 19th and 13th
so from there on um
there's interesting further developments
going on in a sense that
many um physicists at the time
in europe were rather concerned by the
developments of the nazi party in
germany
in the 40s already after the start of
the second world war albert einstein
wrote a letter to
cyril roosevelt pointing out that
there is a real threat that the nazis
are going to develop a bomb
based on nuclear processes
and so this then led to the manhattan
program in the us and the development of
the first nuclear bombs
or atom bombs and in 1945 in august 1945
it was two bombs where
uh dropped on japan which led then to
the
surrender of the japanese empire and the
end of the second world war
um with that i stopped the discussion of
those early developments
i hope you got a first glimpse and use
this as a starting point
to read further you know those
characters lisa meidner for example i'm
looking at a picture right now
um you know very very interesting to see
how those people were connected
on how those people communicated um
and in which environment they had to
work lisa meidna for example was jewish
and she lived in europe i had to flee
from the nazis in the 30s
um while making this kind of discoveries
um also interesting is maybe the
historical introduction to elementary
particles i have this here
um in uh david griffith's book uh this
starts with this kind of classical era
and then goes
uh beyond the second world war and it
introduces the first
the findings in in particle physics
beyond what i
would explain to this point so i hope
you enjoyed this
um this is basically the last of those
introductory lectures which doesn't come
with a set of problems
with a set of things you should be
interacting with um so the next one
i will already do that we will use this
in the thursday
recitation of the first week to
you know have a discussion
you